alright let me close out and let's see
is there any other is this one going on
next
oh this one's already started should I
do this one I'd be starting to when it's
late quickly is that the general
consensus and the twitch chat give me
some feedback click it's two minutes in
all right got three people saying do it
I'm going to do it so alright I'm
starting um back there's somebody
already there's um most people are
already in they're already in their
second game at that point at least okay
that's okay I'm gonna I'm going to do
some extra I'm going to I'm going to
play more dynamically here that although
this turn this uh this game is not
dynamic so far let's rook here let's
learn out blunder Bishop and this game
right now h6 Orsini a6 is on free pawn
right there I'll take it and let's come
back let's just come back and now here
comes another pawn take this and then
this and let's offer some more trades
soon enough Queen on beasts b5 is going
to be safe Knight here's a blunder I
could just take it
now you're right here is pretty good and
let's watch over that f4 square offer a
queen exchange or just get the clean for
free let's take a look I'm okay with
trades let's trade some more push pawns
passed pawn push push push again come
over here and push this guy next he's
going to be the next one to run with
there we go rook takes a seven get this
that let's cut the King off no
resignation stepladder coming up back to
tournament six two one one okay more
dynamic play here Sicilian to any e4
dragon Oh building my Center building my
center right here is this a good idea
okay there's already an issue I think I
think there's already an issue for my
queen let's take that my night out
challenge this pawn nope but it's a free
pawn and let's just move that I don't
want to take here just yet I'm I'm not
castled I get my king right here this is
a safe square also night here is good
it's welcoming more exchanges I have a
giant pawn center giant pawn center and
let's come back over here I'm looking
for a four it could be playing that move
okay
they could be playing Bishop there but
I'm expanding and I'm going to improve
my King position next let's just watch
over this pawn and let's come back over
here and so I improve my King here
sneaking my king up these are safe
squares my King is in a good spot I
could push and then push again and these
rooks are getting crunched here
okay let's open up the a file insist I'd
open up the a file place my Brooke
opposite the King and pawn that cut off
the King welcome exchanges the bishop
here and look for Nate soon two rooks on
the second bad things are about to
happen okay this is going to be made
soon and I'm just looking to protect my
rook and then deliver mate in the corner
defend the rook deliver mate next
okay back to tournament I lost on time
okay so that was easily made up there
it's um these are quicker games here of
course so they're not pairing me up
twenty three minutes remain
six five five four - here we go
efore and then maybe f-4e four are they
moving they're not moving okay
Scandinavian center counter okay my
bishop out let's kick that guy around
whoa are you kidding me look at this
there's no way that could be good
absolutely no way I'm going to pile up
on that pun I'm going to pile up on that
pond and my opponent has been
disconnected this night is going to be
coming here that's where he wants to be
in my rook he wants to be there
Knight here rook here simple to simple
deployment of the pieces half open file
even if you didn't recognize this for
some reason as being a weakness this is
where the RIP belongs half open file a
file where you don't have any pawn
but your opponent does you can't see it
on the stream but it's saying that okay
they resigned there they were also
disconnected at the time so Sicilian I
shouldn't have done that move i pre move
that and I shouldn't but now it's
actually quite all right it's like um a
good a good French defense maybe they'll
give me the H file to work with okay
with that I'm going to cash in here and
then focus on the c-4 square and the c3
pawn in particular oh okay that's all
right
the Bishop's hanging they got to do
something about the bishop let's come
back here light squares okay this is um
this is an issue here here comes b5 but
not so fast let's react to that threat
here comes b5 and let's make it a little
bit more tricky we'll have the week and
a square first before they actually get
that I think I could invest the time for
that and now um that's okay I could work
with that I just oh now that's actually
a bit scary um oh but I have this knight
move right just in time and I'm going to
take this this one out I'm going to take
that one out okay there this is I'm very
very tricky right here let's take this
and then let's make sure I could get
that in actually might be a pawn push
which is strong and it is oh this is
very very scary for me right now I'm not
like in this position at all did they
blender with that move
I think they blended with that I don't
think that they meant to do that
oh man let's take this and we're missing
anything got to get that Bishop out of
there
oh I'm down on time I didn't even
realize oh I've had 27 seconds I was
spending so much time trying to defend I
oh man you see that's what happens when
you're in defensive mode it's so much
more difficult to defend these are
one-minute games ah 51 seconds anybody
know how much time I started out with
that one
ah man okay time to regroup I'm not in
first any more I'm not in first after
that one I was I was nuts and let's just
do that
oh there's night takes here okay let's
defend but no wait a second I got to do
this now this is ugly all right there's
an even uglier one 38 seconds what are
they taking my queen just take my queen
things are gonna be perfect if you take
my queen okay why did I just do that
just move the night
there's discovered discovered attacks
what am i doing
oh my goodness just move here I'm oh
this is awful
okay let's double some pawns even though
it's a half-open G file now watch out
for the mates you know any mates
happening this is I could be taking this
with Czech Queen trade 24 seconds okay I
should probably keep a close eye on the
time since there's very little of it in
these games
there is no G to me what's this Queen
looking to do f2 I have f2 covered and
let's just come here just to be extra
cautious and let's watch that 15 seconds
each let's come over here hitting a c7
next I'm in check oh I'll move the King
mate in two or something get this in
tricks looking for tricks Queen trade
coming
I don't have any time and a pre move
what am i doing I'm gonna come back here
check Oh back to turn when I got that
one the time when I'll take it though 29
18 10 ah man
okay this guy again okay how did this
game go last time I'm forgetting Oh was
um it was the dragon and I had a giant
pawn Center oh this oh hey actually
wasn't I already here before now they
didn't they didn't follow up the same
way much much different now is their
pond there his pond takes let's take
this though I think I could get out of
this I'm just up a piece just up a piece
let me grab this pond first just make
sure that that one goes down and then
everything is going to be quite alright
it's boxed the night out and hit the
bishop and it's ready to be trapped
actually or now forget about trying to
trap it let's just develop but maybe now
I want to do that because they're their
structure is going to be crushed here
very soon my king is going to have a
nice post
so let's attack the Queen side ponds 29
seconds gotta break these ponds down
gotta break them down okay that was
probably a mouse slip 26 seconds let's
grab this and then come back to defend
or attack it I should say
that's it let's give a check
and is this getting to be mate close to
it it's get improving my king position
there's nothing they could do to be
improving their position is this and
then play here and they're running out
of room here my king is going to come up
got all my piece is now focused on that
pond mass exchange is coming up looking
for me
oh wait stalemate issues there might be
there might be stalemate issues okay not
now mate I'll take it back to tournament
41:28 I got to catch this guy 41 28:19
that guy has a 13-point lead already has
six games in like myself but I lost one
of mine was this the guy that I lost to
does anybody know forget that person's
name less than 15 they're not paying me
up there are currently there's only 21
players here
[Music]
here we go oh we both have 28 here
Queens gambit accepted what is going on
here
okay are they going to do a sacrifice on
e4 that might have been available um to
back up I want to get my rooks my rooks
where I should have just taken that what
am i doing oh that was a free pawn I had
three pieces on it
Oh missed a little oh now it's crushing
right everything's falling right now
everything is falling I'm gonna throw in
g4 my queen is ready to be lost
she is definitely ready to be lost here
let's take the knight and throw this in
the bishops trap soon soon the bishop is
going to be trapped or has to be going
somewhere it's probably not too happy
about let's get this rook over here my
king up time is the only issue break
down the dark squares keep dark square
control now and here comes the Queen May
coming up Knight sinking into the
position discover checks on the cards
Oh oh boy here we go
no resignation there it is
that was a fairly quick win I'll take it
forty fifty five forty that guy is
actually pulling ahead even more to two
points this guy again again this is the
third time isn't it whoa they lost a lot
of time right there and let's go let's
go here and get on the light squares are
they going to Castle they might lose the
right to castle if they don't do it
right away and they can't castle where's
their Queen goes well these Knights are
developed classically but how did they
make progress I have a nice Center rook
to b8 is
purposeful Castle as well they might
just do a pond advance maybe I should
have played Bishop c4 this might be a
pawn sack they could have made me run
with a pawn sack just so they could get
castled maybe let's get this night out
of here and then centralize my night and
push my off pawn I have this square
available okay oh no no let's not do
that
I'd be losing material to Bishop to b4
so now let's kick this away and then get
on c5 so that wasn't going anywhere but
okay I guess that's going to be taken
seems like this should have been working
out a little bit better here what are
they really going that direction
oh let's throw it now let's not do that
let's let's do this up sit this open
file next I'll bad things about to
happen here okay this is the bad stuff
right here pins I want to just get my
queen there in check I wonder if they
realize that they're in check actually
Oh mate and two one two okay back to
turn with 54 I made up some ground right
there
I wonder if that guy lost or drew or
something or if he's still in the game
and just about to win 55 54 4138 10
minutes to go ten minutes to go here
ah they are not pairing me up here
hmm they are not paint there we go let's
go
got efore French defense and let's uh
watch over this pond to try this
actually no I guess off to run with the
pond sack Oh
let's get castled and then looking for
what tricks Queen takes pawn this is bad
news for my opponent bad stuff is going
to happen fast really fast there goes
the dark square bishop and let's hit the
Queen first I'm going to actually get it
for free with check and then here comes
the knight domino effect two pieces
back-to-back and let's come back here
hit the Queen looking for this diagonal
now this is going to be brutal
discover checks get my other night in
free up my Queen to move right here
Queen f3 stuff a lot of lot of bad
things happening me there's got to be
mate soon oh this is a pretty mate
two nights I'll take it 71 70 42 41 8
minutes left this guy's just a point
ahead might come down to who could get
in a game quicker
let's go 71 70 are we going to have a
quick resignation come on they're not
even pairing me up here okay maybe maybe
I'll end up getting paired up against
the leader tempo tempo let's put a
question to it okay I want to get this
move in and then push that night around
coming up break this down and then what
I am on this I'm gonna sidestep that
though no that's pretty crazy let's not
do that come the Queen's the Queen's are
off and this is very very scary right
now very very scary territory right here
let's go with this oh man bad things are
about to happen okay hopefully this
works out okay let's get that Bishop out
of there and hit this night before it's
too late
okay let's block this box this out I
think I should be alright let's
challenge this rook bishop pair I want
to watch over a five here we go okay now
I have the bishop here in an open
position let's see if I could put it to
use my ponies wanting a draw but I do
not want to draw okay let's back up I
shouldn't I should have gone there I'm
dropping upon now crap why didn't they
take the pawn they must have just missed
that okay now I'm not going to miss it
get this pawn up hang on King position
pawns are on both sides of the board
this is where you could see I'm the
bishop really show its strength just I
do have to watch out for Forks and
actually night right there could've been
pretty good I'm looking to undermine
that night and just advance my pawns now
I'm on that night again I could take it
how much time do I have I have enough
time plenty of time here let's grab
these pawns really really quick and then
come over here stepladder
checkmate they're not moving back to
tournament 88 that guy has another still
a point ahead 89 88 I'm in second place
one point back how much time is left I
didn't I didn't know how much time was
left there was open Sicilian okay this
could get pretty nuts not going to take
I'll throw in this check and then just
capture if the bishop blocks but no I
want to keep that pin and I'm going to
retreat to d3
okay let's take like this looking for c6
also looking for Bishop here maybe
they're going to grab this pot and I
could exploit that somehow rook to b1
and then piling up on the d7 night 295
rook rook b1 to b3 chase the Queen off
of this diagonal then plane in Knight to
e5 I think that could be pretty good if
the Queen plays here okay so Queen b3
coming up if they take another pond ight
here okay I can just play here right
away and now I don't know that they
could to defend this my bishop is
covering that square as well so I've got
some material I let's come here looking
for tricks looking for tricks here let's
go with this I don't want this to be an
issue and it's offer Queen exchange
although it's three pawns for the piece
three pawns for the piece is a so sure
about that
they don't have much time though just
going to pre move some stuff I need to I
need to finish these games fast nope not
that one let's do this to go fast here
just do moves that I know I could be
making just to burn their time Bishop
here thrown a check back to tournament
that was a quicker win 109-108 four
minutes left about two more games two
more games no more than that I would
think 109-108 come on somebody knocked
that guy off let's go they're not
pairing me up this is killing me ah
109-108 this guy again okay
oh okay I thought maybe that there could
be a fork on c7 maybe there still could
be no I could um okay I'm going to take
this give up my dark square Bishop see
what they want to do all right and now
can I get that pawn back I think I could
now dark squares are they going to be
that much of an issue I don't know about
that I see this as an advantage for me
let's do this first take that light
square Bishop let's do this I met my
knight to watch over my knight and
defend it get my bishop here or my rook
here and it's Castle double up on the C
file and crash through on c3 I could
have also grabbed that pawn and I
probably should have okay so let's move
the knight away and like hit that pond
and get the rooks in position now
crashing through winning a lot of
material free bishop quick resignation
Knight to d1 got more material come on
just resign there it is back to term at
128 109 that's what I needed
pulling ahead right here let's go let's
go let's go four pawns attack all right
let's let's do this I don't want to
shatter my central structure here Bishop
d3 was probably better anticipating that
Knight move so this I lost some time
doing this they take my bishop okay that
was a bad bishop anyhow let's support my
center I don't want to take with the
pond like this because of a fork
possibly let's pin the knight could also
grab here let's back up if they're doing
this they're weakening f5 I want to get
my knight right here but let's let's get
this first but I guess I can't do both
could I
okay let's guard that let's come all the
way back
take my knight okay they're not taking
the knight here comes f5 let's get rid
of this guy this has to be really strong
there's got to be Forks coming up here
to open up the Kings side a little bit
Knight g4 and then Queen to see one
coming up
looking for tricks queen the g5 stuff
from night to g3 night to g3 to h4 h5
excuse me push this I also had Forks
available there it is that's the fork
quick resignation 25 another fork same
square let's get over here Queen here
and let's get back like this
take my knight I should just taken the
bishop let's try this again burning time
here another fork get that Bishop out of
there I don't want have to deal with it
check and let's do this okay now why are
they not resigning here okay this is
brutal here mate in what one two they're
letting their time tick now back to
tournament how much time is left only 45
seconds oh are you kidding me I need a
quick resigner 149 to 148 this
tournament or this the next game isn't
going to finish quick resign quick
resign oh come on
resign let's that guy loses is that guy
ready to lose or something I got to go
for an each H pawn attack or something
can I get a quick mate quick mate come
on oh come on mate into or something
mate in one don't run away King mate and
to just move yes I got I got a win there
it is whoo I'll take it
sorry forgetting loud right there it
just happened right there I won right at
the last second right at the last second
you saw right there oh man all right
right at the last second the guy didn't
have to move
oh man lucky lucky that was nuts right
there
whoo good games all it's not that last
win right in there you see what happens
when you throw that H pun those that are
new to chests will be like I'm going to
throw up I'm going to throw that H pond
down like that cuz I'm going to try and
get a mate like that that is not a good
idea that is strictly first bullet play
fast time controls look at that that's
worth another quick look how many moves
was that that was a 15 mover I had 45
seconds to do something there my queen
swung over mates check you see they
didn't have to move if they didn't move
right here they could have just let the
clock tick that would have been it right
there and literally as soon as I
captured that rook this thing came up
first place just enough time oh man I'll
take it